[Music]
all right we begin tonight with
president Trump's very powerful and
historic first State of the Union
address though he touched on several key
themes American culture referencing the
flag and standing for a national anthem
he also touted the massive economic
growth that has happened in just a
little over a year and of course
businesses creating jobs record low
unemployment and of course rising wages
the president declared a new American
moment and that there has never been a
better time to start living the American
dream
president also listed how he's
fulfilling very key conservative
principles tonight by appointing
conservative justices and judges
honoring and helping vets energy
independence and one of the best lines
of the night that stood out for me the
president said the era of economic
surrender is over now it's best when the
president can push aside the biased
filter of the liberal mainstream media
like he did tonight and speak directly
to you the American people whose so
obvious during many moments in the
speech tonight that the Democrats he'll
never give this president a fight a shot
but his list of accomplishments they do
speak for themselves after eight years
of failure and a year of solid record
success you would think that the never
Trump crowd the hate Trump crowd that
they would appreciate America is now
moving in the right direction people are
getting back to work off of food stamps
the economy is growing now tonight is
the ninth of the president he was able
to bypass everyone and go right to the
American people make his case that his
programs that his policies that his
principles are working and that we the
American people we are rising up in the
world and you would think this would be
a moment people would celebrate not
about the media not about the Democrats
sitting on their hands often looking
like fools not about the hatred of the
president not about liberal conspiracy
theories or obstruction it has really
become a battle for the vision of the
America that you want this to me is a
fork in the road moment and that's
pretty much what tonight was all about
so ask yourself this when what was the
last time the media ever talked or even
mentions the president's numerous
accomplishments in just one year
your answer is probably never and since
the media ignores everything the
president has been able to do we decided
to do their job for them take a look at
the side of your screen we'll run it
throughout the night tonight
the president's accomplishments in one
year the economy is booming we have
record low unemployment numbers
regulations are being gutted Isis
defeated the individual mandate repealed
we are finally on the path to energy
independence and that means millions of
high-paying career jobs for Americans
and America is now back leading on the
world stage now this has been an epic
first year for the Trump administration
and more importantly an epic year for
the American people the Forgotten men
and women that Martha was just talking
about and that's with Democrats that
have resisted every second of every day
obstructed at every single turn and of
course never Trump bruised establishment
Republicans in Congress that have held
back the Trump agenda get the media that
worship Barack Obama defended his
terrible failed policies for eight years
they're not willing to give this
president a break or credit for anything
and they have been so abusively biased
something we've never seen in American
history the media seemingly wants the
president to fail they're actively
rooting for it which is why speeches
like tonight helped the president
explained his vision for this country
without the spin without the smears from
the liberal media